Who is
the god like Yahweh the god
of wrath the god of Mercy
The God Who reaches down to
unworthy people.
It sure is good to be together this morning church.
Go ahead and take your copy of God's word and turn to Micah chapter
4 with me if you would.
Open the app scroll down Micah 4.
Actually going to slip into chapter 5 a little bit.
Now normally I start a sermon with some kind of.
creative illustration or personal story or
something else to get our minds working towards what God has
for us in his word.
But today I feel that it's just right to start by acknowledging the
pain and suffering that many people are feeling right
now.
for various reasons various causes
It's been a hard week for a lot of people including me
including our church, including our city
including the world. I mean, it's
it's everywhere. In fact his Elders on Tuesday night. We just
spent an extended time of focused prayer for the emotional
needs in our church.
Those that we know about and those that
we don't know about.
Maybe for you. It's a new diagnosis.
or inflation hitting you hard
or it's conflict in your family. That just doesn't seem to end.
Or it's the political situation in our nation.
Or maybe it's one of the three deaths that we had in the last three
days in our church.
including
David Bolivar who write down on the front row every
week and
So could be one of those things for you or
it could be.
What happened with the police officer this week and your families affected by
that or you're just worried about things or maybe it's
even shame from your past.
There's just this emotional struggle and it's pain that
you're feeling some of you might even be to the point where you
feel like this as Saints of old have called The Dark
Night of the Soul.
You feel like God is absent like how could God ever be here and
stuff like this or where you feel like, it's just
all hopeless and there's no way out of this.
First let me remind you something that you don't have
to suffer in silence.
let someone in
Here, it's okay. Not to be okay here.
Want to be able to face things head on difficult.
Situations the Bible commands us to weep with those
who weep.
So this is a part of what it is to be a church.
But here's the problem that I've found over the years of ministry. Is that
most people
Have no theological understanding of suffering.
Can't figure out no way to
grasp what God is doing in the middle of pain.
And so what we do with the pain instead?
Is we medicate it?
We avoid it.
Even deny it.
But that kind of a perspective on pain and suffering
misses the truth. We're gonna see in Micah for
today.
a truth that for them back then sparked this
sustaining hope
But also I believe a hope that can sustain us.
And change us just as much today.
It's a hope that while we may feel like
we're in a dark night right now.
Might feel that that is true now.
By God's mercy. The world does not end in
a tragedy.
There's an eternal Sunrise that is coming.
And the pain is not permanent.
It's what Psalm 30 verse 5 says so well in the New Living
Translation, it says weeping may last through the night, but
joy comes with the morning.
Like if you get nothing else today.
It's all centered around that weeping may last through the
night, but joy comes with the morning.
We'll see that in Micah for today.
starting in verse 6 down through chapter 5 verse
In that day declares the Lord I will assemble the
lame and gather those who've been driven away and Those whom I've afflicted.
The lame I will make a Remnant those who were cast
off a strong Nation.
And the Lord will reign over them in Mount Zion from this
time forth and forevermore.
And you owe Tower of the flock Hill of the
daughter of Zion that's talking about Jerusalem to you. Shall
it come the former Dominion shall come kingship for
the daughter of Jerusalem.
Now, why do you cry aloud is there no King
in you?
as your counselor perished
that pain seized you like a woman in labor.
Writhe and groan or push. Oh Daughter
of Zion like a woman in labor.
For now, you should go out from the city and dwell in the Open Country.
You shall go to Babylon.
There you shall be rescued. They're the
Lord will redeem you from the hand of your enemies.
Now many nations are assembled against you saying let
her be defiled let our eyes gaze upon Zion.
But they do not know the thoughts of the Lord.
They do not understand his plan that he's gathered
them as sheaves to the threshing floor.
Rise and thresh. So Daughter of Zion for
I will make your horn iron. I'll make your hoofs bronze.
You shall beat in pieces many people shall devote
their game to the Lord their wealth to the lord of the whole
Earth.
Now muster your troops. Oh daughter of troops.
Siege is laid against us.
With a rod they strike the judge of Israel on the
cheek.
So like we saw last week in verse 1 as Micah
referenced what he said the latter days this phrase here
the that day in verse 6 is also referring
pointing forward to this full and
final reign of the Messiah King.
That day is the day the Messiah
returns that General time around there that
he brings a host of reversals into this upside down
world.
And so Micah is looking forward but unlike
last week.
We was pretty simple to understand how the future Dynamic
of that worked. It was all looking forward to the
end here. It seems like Micah's jumping back and forth.
Between his day and the future and maybe even interim times between
it makes it difficult to understand what he's referring to.
Is he talking about something happening at the moment? He's saying these
things he's talking about some prophetic future event. Is
he talking about even some interim thing that like return from
Babylon? What's he talking about throughout this mix? It
seems like it's back and forth.
Even complicating matters is that profits would often include double
references to things where we have
a historic understanding of something that he says
happened and it did happen, but it's also saying it's going to
happen again someday.
Maybe in a little different way, but it's going to happen someday future.
So it's so confusing. That's why Scholars have
debated these things for centuries.
Just know that I can't explain it in 30 minutes. Okay. So this is
the idea that we're going to have is that there's a lot of muddiness here.
I'm gonna try to make it less money along the way
but there's a lot of confusing things here.
But here's the thing we know for sure.
When we look at this just like I said last week Micah
here is primarily referring to what we
call the kingdom of God.
It keeps referencing mostly the kingdom of
God here that past present future Kingdom
that kind of goes above worldly countries and
people it's like the kingdom of God over all
of this past present future and what Mike is
doing in this section last week. He did this week
again. He's showing what will happen.
as God Reigns in people's hearts
more today
But also what will happen as he reigns someday in
the future on Earth in physical form.
Like that's coming. It's not just we get to get out of here. Go to heaven
that someday. It's coming back to a new heavens and new
earth here.
That's how we're going to apply this today. There's there's going to
be some things we look at both prophetically forward and
what will happen in some specific things. But also, how
does this matter for us today?
How is this valuable for our daily lives?
We'll see a couple truths first.
The truth to observe here is that in the kingdom of God weakness is
shaped into strength.
We learn this right here weakness is
shaped into strength, especially clear versus six through
eight.
He mentions the lame.
You afflicted.
The cast off driven away one.
He talks about those who are weak.
Leave labeling out. All this groups of people that we don't know who is who but
but they're all weak ones. But what he says is that they will
now be gathered back into the land and they will be made into a strong
Nation now,
Even the former Dominion the former King ship shall
come back to Jerusalem.
To the city remember at the end of chapter three we saw was
about to be destroyed by the enemies. It says no, it's
actually going to come back someday.
to this location
what that means the whole time is that God had not forgotten them.
That the Sheep had been injured the Sheep had been scattered,
but the great Shepherd would gather his flock back
together.
Those who trust him. That's what he calls The Remnant those who
trust in him as their king would be gathered around
this Tower in verse 8. Now.
What's about the tower? Well, that's an illustration of safety.
Because they would build up part of their land and that would
be where the shepherd would stand up high and he would watch and
scan for threats that were coming to his flock
that he was wanting to protect. Of course. They would
gather around the tower and Micah says that Tower
is going to be Jerusalem again someday.
Which means it's gonna be a safe place.
It's gonna be a place that God's people can come to and be
safe because
God would be among his flock there.
Not just because it's a walled City. But because God himself
is back among his flock. That's
what makes them.
a strong Nation
now we know looking historically there was a limited fulfillment of
this promise.
A couple hundred years later from when Micah wrote this as
Ezra and Nehemiah led the Exiles back into Jerusalem.
They began to rebuild the city it began to look a little
bit like this.
But not fully right?
So we know ultimately that verse 7 indicates. It
says fourth time forth and forevermore. This is
talking about the Eternal Kingdom.
When when God fully destroys
his enemies and he reigns fully Forever
on the earth. This is talking about that
time that day right the latter days.
It's talking about that time where he reigns and all those
who had been afflicted by their own sin. And by
other people's sin if they trust in the king,
they'll be safe. They'll be home. They'll be secure.
What a promise to look forward to right.
Think about these people who are under such threat the enemy
Assyrians were right on the outside of their walls and they're hearing this
and say, okay, even if this thing gets destroyed it's coming back. Someday God's
gonna take care of us. He's going to protect us.
They thought all hope was lost. But no Micah says it's coming
back.
But also think for us today that knowing this is coming for us. There's
a day that all will be secure. There'll be no more pain in sorrow
and suffering.
It's good news.
But think think now a little more deeply into
this about how this this weakness into
strength idea. How does that relate to us? How does that affect our
day-to-day lives both individually and as
a church, how does this
Change us.
How does it change our attitudes how we're respond to other people
how we view people? How does weakness into strength and the
kingdom of God change us?
first it means
That you don't have to have it all together to be a part of this Kingdom.
Did you notice God is going after?
the lame
The Afflicted the outcasts The Driven away God is
pursuing them. Now
we know those conditions had to do with their own sin primarily. It's
the reason they were that way but even
if it was someone else's sin, it's still affected
them.
And they were they were hurting they were outcasts. And
so they're feeling this separation feeling this Exile from
God that there was such distance.
Yet God was pursuing them.
He was inviting them into his secure
home if they would trust him.
He sang Come On In.
Which in fact is the entry point to the kingdom of
God?
Jesus said it Matthew 5 verse 3. He said blessed
are the poor in spirit.
For theirs shall be the kingdom of heaven.
Right that poverty of spirit.
It's not that just you.
Were downcast and you think lowly of
yourself. It's the idea that you have a humble recognition
of your sin your weakness your separation from
God and you bring nothing to the table. That's the
poverty of spirit. But in that acknowledgment you then
come to Jesus.
You come to him and say Lord. I
need you. I need your life death and Resurrection in
my place to count for me. I cannot do
this on my own. I am weak. I am in darkness.
I need you.
Here's the reality of our world that we live in.
It will scream to you.
Only the Strong Survive
don't show weakness climb on other people to
get what you want, right? That's what the world says. But
God does not notice. God does not turn
weak people away from the kingdom of God.
Which actually pulls them in?
He goes after them and says you're weak. Come on, you're weak.
Come on.
He gives Grace to those who acknowledge their weakness.
He gives Grace to them.
And so start there.
Start there.
Because here's what God does with it.
When we acknowledge that we are weak and
we get to that place. What he does is he uses weak ones
for his glory.
He turns in the kingdom of God. He turns weakness into
strength.
Just listen to First Corinthians 1.
Versus 26 through 31. He says consider your
calling not many of you were wise according
to worldly standards. Not many were powerful
not many were of noble birth. But God chose
what is foolish in the world to shame the wise God
chose? What is weak in the world to shame the
strong God chose? What is low and despised in
the world even things that are not to bring to nothing things that are
so that no human being might boast in the presence of God.
And because of him you are in Christ Jesus who became
to us wisdom from God righteousness sanctification
Redemption so that as it
is written let the one who boasts boast in the Lord.
Did you see what that said?
It said that you might be weeping through the night
of life right now.
Even just comparatively where you're you're looking
around everybody else seems to be strong. Everybody else seems to have it all together and
you know, you don't and so you're you're weeping you're
through the dark but hear me joy comes with the morning.
This is the kingdom of God. This is what Jesus does in you
and and he gives joy and it's not just in
how he uses you. He gives you Joy just in him in
his salvation just in his presence that
he would invite you in include you a part
of his family like just be in that for a second, right?
There's joy that God would choose a
weak one like you a weak one like me and say come
on into my family.
Never earn. It. Don't deserve it. Come on.
Joy in that church.
But then understand this too. We saw it here that
that even more joy comes whenever the Lord
uses you.
For his purposes his kingdom principle purposes.
And I know some of you're sitting there saying well.
How can he ever use me?
I don't have any big gifts. I can't speak on the stage. I don't have much of
money and you know my past I mean, you know
what I've done. How could God ever use me? Yes, you're thinking
that but you have to remember this. It's not about you.
You're the tool in the Master's Hand, right?
Did you notice something? Look how many times in Micah 4 God says?
I will assemble I will gather I
will make them the remnant I will make
them a strong Nation. I will reign over them. It's
not about you.
Yeah, you're weak. He acknowledges that you're weak. But he
chose the weak to shame the strong who think they're strong.
That's why the kingdom entry point is humble faith.
Because listen if I think that that all that I can do
is because I'm so awesome and I got all the gifts and
I've got all the abilities who gets the glory for that.
I do.
But if I acknowledge the truth about
my life that I am so weak that
I really am by the grace of
God everything that I am like if I have an honest acknowledgment
of my true self, then who gets the
glory whenever God works through me.
Feed Us
That's the point of this.
It's been said this way. I love this quote. God created the world out of
nothing.
As long as you are not yet, nothing God
cannot make something out of you.
You've got to acknowledge weakness and
and that you are really nothing and that God then does something
miraculous in you and through
you.
Because in the kingdom of God weakness is shaped into strength.
It's backwards. I know.
But that's how God shows himself off.
That's what second Corinthians 12 verses 9 and 10
says
but he said to me my grace is sufficient for
you.
For my power is made perfect in weakness.
Therefore I will boast all the more gladly of my
weaknesses so that the power of Christ May
rest upon me.
For the sake of Christ, then I am content with weaknesses
insults hardships persecution calamities.
For when I am weak.
I'm strong.
In the kingdom of God, he turns weakness into strength.
Here's the second truth. We observe in Micah 4 about this Kingdom.
Suffering is shaped into character.
I said before there's a lot of Yoyo in this verse These passages.
Regarding the time when things are happening. They were going to go through suffering.
That was talked about a lot through this. There's a lot of struggle they're
going through but God in verse 10 in his grace.
God would redeem them. It's a beautiful word that word
redeem used all over the Old Testament talking about
purchasing back a lost object.
It's with Ruth that whole story kinsman redeemer. That's that's part of that. Same
word that God says here. He's going to redeem his
people out of the land of Babylon.
So this is not all bad news.
But notice something in verses 9 and 10,
I'm gonna read those again. I want you to look at these two
verses look for the imperatives the commands here.
Verse 9. He asked the question. Why do you cry out? Is there no King in you?
Talking about like they forgot that they had a
king really was God has your counselor perished that
pain sees you like a woman in labor. Now. Look at this.
Rise grown or push?
O Daughter of Zion like a woman in labor now, you
shall go out from the
city you shall dwell in the Open Country. You
shall go to Babylon. Those are commands.
But there you shall be rescued and we see this hope they're the
Lord of redeem you from the hand of your enemies. You see the commands
there though.
There were commands given God said through Micah. He's
commanding them to suffer like
a woman in labor.
By the way, remember at this time there were no epidurals. So this was
like the full thing, right?
He says you're going to suffer. That's what God is
comparing to this Exile that was about to come. He's saying
you're gonna have to go through this. You're gonna be rescued. Yes,
but you have to go through this now.
their job
was to endure the discipline that
God was bringing due to their sin and Rebellion.
think about this metaphor though for a second this childbirth metaphor
he gives
Absolutely terrible suffering for a season, but the end
result of bringing forth that baby is worth
it.
And even the glory of the
birth and the baby that you get on
the other end is magnified by the enduring of the
suffering to get there.
It's worth it even more because of what you go through to get there.
That's what Yahweh was doing here with his people.
He had to discipline them.
To tear down their sin so that
he could build up them again in righteousness and
holiness.
They're pain had a purpose.
To refine them to change them that they
wouldn't have learned any other way, but they had to go through this to understand.
It's the same for us today, isn't it?
When God disciplines those he loves.
God's purpose is not
Revenge
or Vengeance or anger his purpose his
growth correction.
It's what Hebrews 12 says.
Verses 5 through 11 says have you forgotten the
exhortation that addresses you as Sons?
My son do not regard lightly the discipline of the Lord
nor be weary when reproved or corrected by
him for the Lord disciplines the one he loves.
chastises every son who he receives
It's for discipline. You have to endure.
God is treating you as Sons for what son is
there whom his father does not discipline.
If you're left without discipline in which all have participated your
illegitimate children not Sons.
Besides us we've had Earthly fathers who disciplined us
and we respected them. Shall we not much more be subject to
the father of spirits and live.
For they discipline us for a short times it seem best to them. But God
disciplines us for our good that we
may share his holiness.
For the moment all discipline seems painful rather
than Pleasant.
But later it yields the peaceful fruit of righteousness to those
who have been trained by it.
So you see it right there that often for us to
get where we need to be.
For us to get where God wants us to
be.
We have to be disciplined.
But don't ever forget God. Does that out of love for
you?
It's not Vengeance. It's not spite. He does it out of
love when we blow it when we make a mess of Our Lives. God
loves us enough to redirect us toward
his right way. He wants better for us. He doesn't
want us to walk down that path is going to destroy us and others.
He loves us too much.
Let us go that way.
They brings us back. Of course, it seems painful. Like when when
you're a discipline as a child. You don't look at your parents. Say
yeah, thank you. That was awesome like you it's not pleasant.
painful
But we can't get to the peaceful fruit of righteousness.
Without being trained by God's discipline
in our lives.
part of the deal
and so I think we understand that inherently. I think we get the fact
that I blew it. I need to be disciplined so I can grow. Yes, we get
that.
But here's what's harder to grasp.
The times in our lives when we suffer.
And it's not our fault.
When we suffer because of someone else's sin.
And there's even times in our lives other other times where we
just we suffer just because we live in a broken world.
Because we live in a fallen world and people die and
cancer happens and it's not anybody's fault necessarily.
Like those are the harder ones to understand, right?
But hear me even in all of that.
Even in those moments of suffering. God uses
even that to shape you.
To change you to bring about character in
your life.
That's what Romans 5 verses 3 through 5 says.
Not only that but we rejoice in
our sufferings.
Knowing that suffering produces endurance and endurance
produces character and character produces hope
and hope does not put us to shame because God's
love has been poured into our hearts through the Holy
Spirit who has been given to us.
in other words if you allow it to
if you allow God to work in you through
your suffering then God will bring character in
your life.
And that character leads to Hope because it's not.
Judgment God's love has been poured into
our heart. It's out of love that he's disciplined. He's
suffering these allowing these things to happen because he loves you
enough to give you hope in the middle of all of it.
See our understanding of suffering must be based in the
sovereignty of God.
That if we have repented and believed in Jesus in
our place, if we are his by faith, we
can believe that everything he does
everything he allows is because he does love us.
We may not understand why.
And we might not even like it.
We might grow as we suffer through it.
But we can have hope.
That just like he was going to redeem them from the Exile. He
is Our Redeemer as well and that
for those who love God all things work together
for good for those who are called according to his purpose Romans. 8:28
says
And what is that purpose the very next verse verse 29 the purpose
is to be conformed to the image of his son.
character
everything in our lives works for his purpose and that's
to make us look more like Jesus.
I rarely recommend books in sermons, but
this one.
by Elizabeth Elliott
called suffering is Never for Nothing.
Would be well worth your investment.
If you don't know her story, she has a great perspective on terrible trials in
life. Her husband was killed as a missionary.
She knows.
But listen to one of the quotes from the book, she said I
don't know what you're going through talking to you or me. I don't
know what you're going through but I can say that I know the
one who knows.
And I have come to see that it's through the deepest suffering
that God has taught me the deepest lesson.
in the kingdom of God
suffering is shaped into character.
So when life is hard?
Don't throw your hands up and say forget this I give up.
When life is hard don't seek relief in the wrong places. Don't
don't run after things that would hurt you.
No instead press into the Lord.
Seek him in the darkness you're walking in
knowing that this light and momentary Affliction is preparing
for us an eternal weight of Glory. That is beyond
all comparison these four 17
This light and as heavy as it feel light
and momentary affliction.
It's preparing us for something.
infinitely better
morning is coming.
The Eternal Sunrise is coming one day daylight
is near so get ready.
There's one more aspect of the kingdom of God. We find here in
this passage.
It's that threat is shaped into victory.
Thread is shaped into victory.
I want to read again chapter 4 verse 11 down through
chapter 5 verse 1
Micah looks at his
contemporaries. He says many nations are assembled against you now.
And they're saying let her be defiled let our eyes gaze upon
Zahn. Maybe they're wanting to destroy the city, but they do
not know the thoughts of the Lord.
They do not understand his plan that he's gathered them
as sheaves to the threshing floor a rise and
thresh show Daughter of Zion. I'll Make Your Horn Iron. I'll
make your hoofs bronze. You shall be in pieces many people's devote
their gain to the Lord their wealth of the Lord the whole Earth.
Muster your troops daughter troops sieges laid
against us.
With a rod they strike the judge of Israel on the
cheek.
So again this roller coaster ride of time
jumps back and forth, but some of the seems like
it's happening right around Micah in the moment some of it seems like it's future. It's
gonna happen someday.
So what do we do with this?
We can nitpick and discuss and debate
for hours over the details here. But here's what here's
what they needed to know. First. The original here is they need to understand that
there was a final Victory coming one day, right?
So hang on right? There's it may look bad now, but
there's a coming a day when everything will be the way
it's supposed to be.
But they would have needed hope to carry on during that day
too, right?
As the swords and Spears clattered around outside the
walls and they're like, how do we even hang on today? That's
what Micah showed him.
that even though
the enemy seemed to be dominating Judah at
that time.
God had a plan in all of it.
I read it this week in a commentary. It said the enemies think they
have a brilliant plan to gather at Jerusalem, but actually
it is God who's Gathering them?
They want to destroy Jerusalem, but in the end God will
Thresh and destroy the Nations who attacked Jerusalem.
They want to desecrate Zion and loot its Temple, but
Zion will end up consecrating the enemy's wealth
to God.
Like God was turning weakness into strength. We saw that here. He's
turning this threat into victory.
He flipped it on him. He said come on in. Come on in guys. Come on in.
Come to Jerusalem gather around.
for one purpose
which in fact if you go back and read Isaiah chapter 37, we
we seek God in part fulfill This Promise by
miraculously destroying 185,000 Assyrian
troops at one time.
They all gathered around Jerusalem and then goth
wipes out 185,000
So I know that there's a lot going on here and some of this is still future. There's
still things happening. But the overall point to this is that those who
arrogantly oppose God will not
have the last say
They will be defeated.
That's the opposition they're facing and God says.
One day it will be complete.
See, that's the picture that Micah was painting for us here. Is
that even if it seems like all hope is
lost.
Hope is actually still there.
Hope is still present. How can we be so sure though.
Because manager looks like these enemies are going to take us out.
How can we be so sure that hopes still alive and
we're going to Exile for the next however, many like we don't know what's gonna
happen on the back end. How can we be so sure?
Because our God will win the battle.
He will show himself Victorious.
They've seen Farmers threshing out the grain. They know what that looks
like and they see now that God will strengthen them and
God will strengthen us to overcome the enemy.
But again, it's not because we have any strength in ourselves. It's
because Jesus has overcome the world already.
See, this is the gospel. Hope we have just how this all
comes forward to us today.
Because think about how dark it was.
When Jesus like chapter 5
verse 1 was being struck on the
face with a rod by the religious leaders.
Think of how the darkness fell on the world as Jesus
is up on the cross for hours and darkness how
dark it was at that time. Think about how dark it
was for those three days when he was in the Tomb think
out life was dark in so many ways.
But Sunday's coming, right?
just think
of that glorious morning
when light burst out of the darkness when life
burst out of death
all hope had seemed lost all hope had seemed like
it was gone to the Wayside defeat seemed
inevitable. The enemy was laughing because he thought he
won at that time, but then it all turned around into Eternal
Victory through this Messiah named Jesus.
that the threat
turned into victory
the very thing the enemy tried to do
to destroy the king actually brought victory for
the king.
And not only that first John 5 verse 4 says if
we trust in Jesus we share in that
Victory, too.
It's not just we're looking up here like congratulations clapping
for the king. We share in that
Victory as well. That's what the kingdom of God does
Church.
That threats may come threats trials will
be experienced and if we don't have any hope in those then
of course, there's every reason to give up.
Hope is the thing that people need right now, right?
If we don't have any hope, let's just give up we might as well just throw in
the towel. We're done. Yeah, of course, it shouldn't last but
if we trust in him
if we trust in this King this Messiah the
Savior the Victor that means we have the
strength of his might in US.
That means that we are being shaped into
his character through all of it.
And that means that we have the Assurance of Victory
on the other side of this.
That's why.
We have hope to carry on no matter what we face every
day.
We don't know when God's gonna bring all this to pass.
We just know he will.
So hold on Church.
Weeping may last through the night.
But joy comes with that morning.